IT'S TIME TO PLAY FAKIN' IT.
FAKIN' IT.
(CHEERING)
THE TUMBLR GHETTO-ASS FAKES
FEATURES PICTURES OF COSTUMED
CHARACTERS WHO LOOK LESS LIKE
THEY PARADE AROUND TIME SQUARE
AND MORE LIKE THEY GOT MUGGED
THERE.
COMEDIANS, I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU
A PICTURE OF ONE OF THESE
CHARACTERS AND I WANT YOU TO
GIVE ME THEIR CATCHPHRASE.
THE FIRST ONE...
LOOK AT THIS HOT MESS SMURFETTE.
WOW.
SHE LOOKS LIKE SHE SHOULD BE
EATING CHIPS OFF THE FLOOR OF A
TRAIN.
(DINGS)
YES, JEN?
>> SHE HASN'T BEEN THE SAME
SINCE SMURF COBAIN DIED.
(LAUGHTER)
>> HARDWICK: OH, MY GOD.
YEAH.
(APPLAUSE)
I'LL GIVE YOU POINTS, JEN
KIRKMAN.
>> YOU BETTER.
>> SMURF...
>> HARDWICK: UH...
SHE'LL GIVE YOU BLUE BALLS.
NEXT ONE, THIS ANOREXIC COOKIE
MONSTER WITH A FANNY PACK...
(DINGS)
YEAH, MIKE?
>> ME ALSO ROOFIE MONSTER.
>> HARDWICK: I'LL GIVE YOU
POINTS.
JERMAINE?
>> HI. I'M SHIA LABEOUF AND
THIS IS MY COMMUNITY SERVICE.
(LAUGHTER)
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
NEXT ONE.
THIS MISS PIGGY WHO'S SEEN
SOME LIFE.
(DINGS)
HAPPENS, SHE'S REALLY SEEN
SOME SHIT, THIS ONE.
MIKE LAWRENCE.
>> THEY'LL LET ANYONE COHOST THE
VIEW.
(LAUGHTER)
POINTS.
JEN?
>> UH, BALD IN THE BACK, BUT
GREAT IN THE SACK.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
NEXT ONE.
THIS CHESS PLAYING CHICKEN IN A
TRACKSUIT...
JERMAINE?
>> NAH.
>> HARDWICK: OKAY. MIKE?
(LAUGHTER)
>> NAH.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, MIKE?
>> EVERYTHING WENT TO HELL WHEN
THE DARK MEAT MOVED INTO THIS
NEIGHBORHOOD.
(LAUGHTER)
>> WOW, MAN, WHY YOU DO THAT?
ON TV? WE WERE COOL, MAN.
(LAUGHS)
>> HARDWICK: SHOULD I GIVE HIM
POINTS?
>> OH, YEAH, GIVE HIM THE
POINTS, YEAH.
>> HARDWICK: OKAY, POINTS,
MIKE LAWRENCE.
ALL RIGHT, LAST ONE.
THIS KITTY WHO COULDN'T BE
BOTHERED TO TRY.
(DINGS)
(AUDIENCE GROANS)
OH, MY GOD.
YEAH, JEN?
>> OH, YOU'VE MISTAKEN ME.
I'M NOT A CHARACTER IN TIMES
SQUARE.
I'M JUST A 15-YEAR-OLD GIRL
VISITING FROM JAPAN.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.